welcome from the Chess Club and
scholastic center of st. Louis this is
Ryan and I'm Katherine we're first in
your heart but last in chess
welcome back to blenders we made the
steak so you don't have to Catherine
what's on the agenda for today
well Ryan we've been asking you guys for
your blenders and you actually system to
us and today we're going to talk about
this letter is from chess back home user
and one reviewer harsh ooh 97 so I want
you to take a second maybe pause the
video and think about what white might
be on the lookout for because our 397
does not see it I move Knight to c3
Knight c3 let's go to me Catherine
develops a piece off the back row lose
the Knights in the center I don't see it
I don't see the problem
ah well Ryan you're one of the many who
ends up gamma bishop I see now what
should Harsha 97 have done one
possibility is to move to a for
preventing the trap but there's a
variety of other things that he could
have done
however since over a year ago Vasundhara
she was a beginner now I'm sure he's a
much stronger player Stefan did you know
there's a common motif or the Bishop
Bishop gets trapped called the Noah's
Ark trap Oh what exciting information
Ryan Greg how do we move on to our next
wonder sound good
all right the next team was sent in by
YouTube viewer panda penny and she was
playing white in this game this is
called a lizard trap maybe you've heard
of it Catherine you know what Ryan I'm
not heard of a lizard trap well we'll go
over later I think yeah so white plays
d4 black plays Knight f6 pandas then
decided to put her knight on D 2 which
is questionable black play d5 white
takes now black plays Knight g4 here so
pause the video at home and see what you
wish your players panda Catherine what
would you play if you're playing white
here you know I think that I would move
my king side Knight to f3
good idea let's see what panda penny
really plays who h3 that does not look
good so the pilot h3 is that blacks
going to move his knife to e3 one
trapping the Queen and two losing the
game pretty soon because once that Queen
comes out like a lizard checkmate
you know if it because it's like a
wizard or if it pops like a lizard is it
scooped up really quickly like a lizard
possibly because it's a game played by
frederique Lazard no I think it's more
of a lizard's tail I think we can agree
to disagree on this one Ryan well no
there are these lizard II I'm pretty
sure it's the lizard oh well you take
potato I say potato you say lizard I say
lizard well thank you for watching
another episode of blenders and those in
submitted thank you for submitting and
we hope we get a few more submissions
this week yes please send your blunders
into info at st. Louis chess club org
and this week harshing 97 in panda penny
both be winning autographed pictures of
Fabiano carolina very exciting thanks
again and we'll see you next week
so Catholic that is called the lizard
it's a lizard game no I think you're
making this up the game is played by
Frederick Lazard so it's called Lazard
we have lizard look it's a fact well
it's an alternative fact that it's a
lizard